hello and welcome to your seventh WX
Python tutorial in this tutorial we're
going to be working on some
customization of this window most
notably in the panel and as always we
want to do this with a bit of
interaction with the user since that's
what it's all about these days is user
interaction and customized ability based
on the user so if you don't recall where
we left off was here that's their name
and s if they enjoy and then it asks
them what their favorite color is they
click that and up pops in this window so
now what we want to do is like this text
box is in what is known as the panel and
like this kind of area right here is our
panel and so this text box is just
within the panel so let's exit this
window and what we're gonna do first is
change this panel a little bit first
let's move the panel down because
generally just like we did with the
buttons you want all your button
information kind of grouped all your
customizable stuff that's happening back
to back
I think you want that group so you can
kind of find this stuff over time when
you're coming back to change up your
program or whatever it just helps to
have it groups so we're gonna put the
panel stuff actually down here now the
other thing we'd like to do let's go
ahead and make room for some text that
we're going to put on so we're gonna
change the position of this panel
instead we're gonna put it at 3 and a
hundred and then we're gonna change the
size so let's do like more like 150 and
50 so it'll be kind of long and short
and so now what we're gonna do you'll
see it will bring it up in the program
just a second if you can't visualize
that so now let's put something else in
our panel so let's call this awesome
awesome text but we'll just do our text
for short equals W X dot static text and
within the parameters you're gonna have
basically four and the first one we're
going to say panel
and then we'll do negative one for the
ID then you'll have awesome text is what
will have that text say and then you
finally you have the position of it and
so you don't want it to conflict with
this text panel that we have so that's
why we move this text panel down it's
down a hundred pixels so we got plenty
of space but this text will put this
text where at three three so it'll be
three pixels over and through pixels
down so if we run this now
you'll see that we have awesome text
here but let's be honest with ourselves
that text really isn't that awesome so
let's apply some colors to that text so
we'll come down here and the way you do
this is you do aught X obviously then
you're gonna set the foreground for
grant oh my goodness can't type
foreground color set for grant let's
make sure we did that right yep and then
we'll set that color to yellow then
we'll do the same thing we'll set a
background Oh text got set background
color and we'll set that background
color to black okay so we'll save that
we'll run it and up pops this window and
now you can see you okay the text is
looking a little more awesome
now I'll you graphic designers out there
I'm sure you were like okay okay but can
we put hex color codes in there yes you
can
so not only can you like spell out the
colors you can put the hex codes in
there so let's do kind of like a light
blue we'll save that and we'll run it
and just you just put the hex color code
within the parenthesis so it's a string
itself and now you see okay now our
awesome text it's this light blue on top
of black so yes you can do hex color
codes as well so you have you know any
color you could possibly want
and put in there so that's really cool
but I bet you guys want to take it a
step further and let's make this text
like truly custom text based on user
input and what better way to color our
text than to color the text the same
color that the user chose so let's do
that real quick so we'll call this
really attack so for really awesome text
that's gonna be W X dot static text same
thing as before it's gonna go in the
panel it's ideal just be negative one
and then we'll call this customized
awesome miss then we're gonna say it's
location will be same three pixels over
but just so we have plenty of space
we'll do it 30 pixels down now what we
want to do is we'll say really awesome
text equals W X dot static or I'm sorry
it's really awesome text dot set
foreground color and within these
parentheses you can put the users see we
save this as fav color and fav color is
just corresponding to a string so we can
just literally take fav color and copy
and paste that variable right on in
there and then the same thing before let
me just copy and paste this and so we'll
do really awesome text and then we paste
set background color we'll still have
that be black so now when we run this
okay you said Harrison yeah I enjoy it
now I can pick any color we want so
let's say we want green so now we can
see okay the customized awesomeness is
green but what if we want a different
color let's choose up red now it's red
text so now that we've added a little
bit of color I think that especially
nowadays you know in the old days just
having like the most basic GUI was like
oh but this GUI nowadays
is pretty disgusting so we're gonna
continue building on making the GUI just
maybe a little bit more appealing to
somebody so I hope you're looking
forward to that as always thank you for
watching and thank you for my
subscriptions it really helps to see
like the people that support me so
thanks for subscribing and until next
time